bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo
au coeur du parlement européen ici à
bruxelles pour une émission spéciale
avec kathia gilder nous allons recevoir
dans quelques instants quatre invités
que nous allons vous présenter pour
commenter deux faits d'actualité marque
en europe
l'élection présidentielle française bien
sûr mais également la situation
inquiétante en grèce avec nos véronique
de kaiser bonjour eurodéputés belges
vice présidente du groupe des
socialistes et démocrates européens ici
au parlement et à vos côtés le
britannique graham watson député
européen et président de l'alliance des
démocrates et des libéraux pour l'europe
également et pardon également avec nous
andreas eschbach bonjour vous êtes
député européen allemand du groupe ppe
et puis à vos côtés marietta giannakou
vous êtes euro députés grecs également
du groupe ppe
bonjour et bienvenue alors avant d'avoir
vos réactions je vous propose tout de
suite de regarder de voir comment nos
voisins européens nos voisins que vous
représentez ont regardé cette cette
élection comment voit-il l'alternance
tour d'horizon des télévisions d'europe
avec aurélie d'afas
au soir de l'élection la question qui
agite et télévisions européennes c'est
qui est françois hollande la bbc insiste
sur l'ancrage corrézien du nouvel élu en
belgique c'est l'homme normal qui
retient l'attention
à 57 ans les français lui reconnaissent
comme première qualité qu'il est
sympathique bien plus que son premier
adversaire nicolas sarkozy par contre
ils n'auraient pas la stature
présidentielle
mais la stature présidentielle on
l'acquiert quand on y est on devient
président alors que sympathique c'est
pas sûr un homme normal pas excessif
c'est sur ce registre que françois
hollande a donc joué ces derniers mois
au point de l'inscrire sur ces t-shirts
de campagne
et puisque l'homme c'est le programme
qui intéresse les priorités européennes
de françois lang créé l'inquiétude les
dizaines de milliers de personnes qui
attendaient à la place de la bastille
jusqu'aux premières heures du jour ont
pu entendre leur nouveau président
affirmé vouloir mener l'europe dans une
nouvelle direction pour faire de la
croissance une priorité devant
l'austérité
cette annonce à ce que les marchés
aujourd'hui à lens simplifié aux anneaux
outre-rhin on s'interroge effectivement
sur l'avenir des relations franco
allemandes
le journaliste pointe les divergences de
points de vues entre la chancelière
merkel est le nouveau président français
il parle même de conflit françois
hollande doivent se réunir la semaine
pour discuter en au gala merkel a déjà
laissé entendre et appuie la dizaine de
voix certes elle ne peut fera le défaire
et françois hollande ont toute la nuit
alors on maintient sa position c'est une
nouvelle négociation
c'est le coeur du combat et devrait être
mis sur la table pour discuter négocier
bon voilà comment françois hollande est
vu par les télévisions en tout cas par
certaines télévisions européennes
on a dit un président normal moi
j'aimerais savoir comment ça vous fait
réagir ce terme est commandant prouver
vos pays respectifs
éventuellement on voit le fait d'être un
président normal peut-être un petit mot
rapide de chacun d'entre vous véronique
de kaiser peut-être pour commencer je
crois qu'il faut prendre ce terme normal
en comparaison avec ce que sarkozy a été
nicolas sarkozy a été c'est à dire que
il l'a voulu des réformes
indiscutablement l ont aidée dans tous
les sens il a mené la france au au pas
de course un peu comme une girouette et
puis finalement la cravache
il est épuisé quelque part la france
et quand hollande dit je veux changer le
pacte de stabilité et je serai un
président normal c'est une ligne on la
suivra sera dur mais ça ne bougera pas
et on n'a pas le sentiment de cette
course folle dans lesquels finalement
nicolas sarkozy y est mais précipité son
peuple la chronique
je ne pense pas qu'on devient président
si on est une personne normale c'est une
personne qui a beaucoup de qualités qui
est très ambitieux ambitieuse en même
temps un président normal dans le sens
d'être peut-être plus stable plus plus
sur laquelle on peut dépendre de plus et
j'espère un président r aux pistes
parce que l'europe a besoin de la france
et a besoin d'une france qui s'engage
dans le sens la responsabilité le
travail en commun andré fabre vu
d'allemagne
est-ce que c'est rassurant pour en gal
merkel on sait qu'elles avaient des
relations
allez on va dire pas toujours très
harmonieuse parce que les personnalités
très différentes entre je trouve c'est
toujours rassurant ticket karin normal
avec alger la mairie elle n'est pas
normal bien sûr normal voilà
et quand on est normal
mais dire qu'il apporte quelque chose
comme ennemi il apporte quelque chose
plus proche à tout le monde
latéralement pour faire une telle
campagne et pour une personne qui
n'était jamais à l'administration
c'est quelque chose d'anormal
de toute façon l'europe va se créer par
des différences on va en parler dans un
instant d peut-être votre réaction drame
watson comment se le candidat hollande
devenu président ait vu depuis londres
lui qui avait dit qu'il avait mes
troupes à la city qu'elle est je pense
qu'à londres
on a pensé qu'on a besoin d'avoir des
relations assez proche avec les français
je suis heureux que nous avons réussi
surtout dans le domaine de la défense
avoir une coopération importante
important aussi pro pour l'europe et
j'espère qu'avec françois hollande ce
serait possible aussi de trouver des
accords dans d'autres secteurs
il est difficile si nous avons quelqu'un
qui veut vraiment réduire l'âge l'âge de
la retraite de 62 ans à 60 ans quand
aucun gouvernement ne peut pas se le
permettre
en ce moment si c'est quelqu'un qui va
engager encore soit en 2000
enseignants je veux bien je suis
toujours en faveur de l'éducation mais
il faut avoir aussi une responsabilité
les marchés ne permettront pas
malheureusement peut-être pour lui à
françois hollande de faire ce qu'il veut
faire car la dette française sera
attaquée par les marchés dans ce cas là
donc il faut que françois hollande
sincère dont le mainstream de ce qui se
passe en europe
c'est à dire les politiques d'austérité
mais en même temps et je suis d'accord
accompagné avec les mesures de quoi son
circuit économique
c'est aussi votre votre sentiment à la
télévision belge ont beaucoup suivi
cette élection de bout en bout
on a entendu beaucoup de choses des
choses très très différentes et
notamment ce sentiment qu'une présidence
très difficile s'ouvrait pour françois
hollande pour rien gerizier normalement
aujourd'hui tout présidence en europe va
être difficile et où le sait très bien
pour nous évidemment je suis socialiste
c'est ce n'est pas le triangle du
socialisme en europe mais c'est tout de
même une lueur d'espoir que enfin la
question de la relance de l'emploi de la
croissance vont être pris au niveau
européen au sérieux et non pas de
manière subsidiaire et non pas comme
quelque chose à côté de la rigueur alors
là où je suis pas d'accord avec g
oui françois hollande il l'a dit il l'a
écrit il y aura de la rigueur enfin il
n'a jamais dit que c'était
le président qui a les gaspiller des
draps et la rigueur en belgique on la
connaît et on la veut aussi mais ce
qu'on ne veut pas c'est que l'union
européenne impose au nom de cette
rigueur des choix dans le domaine social
quand vous dites bon la retraite à 60
ans ou quand vous dites il va engager
des gens dans l'éducation
et là aussi dit qu'il contiendrait les
fonctionnaires et de ram et ça c'est du
domaine du national laissez lui faire sa
rigueur comme il l'entend penser qu'en
fait comme peuvent en fait là un pays
voisin un autre état européen n'a pas à
se mêler de ce qui se passe dans la
politique nous en belgique on explose
littéralement
parce que alors que nous avons des
résultats économiques qui sont pas
mauvais alors que nous avions de la ring
on it here is pourquoi l'union n'ont pas
le budget parce que l'union européenne
nous dit à la fois qu'on fait de grands
efforts que c'est pas mal du tout mais
qu' on doit revoir notre politique
d'index exemple la fixation des salaires
et on dit halte-là ça vous toucher à la
souveraineté ou toucher ou modèle social
de l'allaitement et véronique a raison
cette année c'est aux nations même
décider quelle politique sociale ils
vont mener mais en même temps nous nous
sommes déjà mis d'accord au niveau
européen qu'on va discuter avant les
budgets de chaque paie on va s'informer
limite ct je suis sûr qu'il y aura une
pression du dj du groupe sur un françois
hollande ou bien david cameron pour un
angle enfin un président de rigueur la
maladie on va voir on va parler
d'ailleurs en détail de ce que va faire
peut-être françois hollande au niveau
européen justement je vous propose de
voir avec sandra cerqueira ce que peut
être cette europe de françois hollande
regarder
je suis sûr que dans bien des pays
européens ça a été un soulagement
un espoir françois hollande avait promis
du changement en europe
sortir de l'impasse de l'austérité en
remettant la croissance au coeur des
débats
une priorité désormais pour tous les
dirigeants de l'union fin mai une
rencontre doit avoir lieu pour préparer
le prochain sommet européen avant
nouveau qui est en train de souffler je
dis pas que tout le monde comme france
contre en soi landes ce que je constate
en revanche c'est que le thème de la
croissance tout ça est en train de
s'affirmer et qu'il a été le premier à
poser ses questions tous pour la
croissance mais deux visions s'opposent
pour y parvenir
d'un côté la proche libéral ce que fait
mario monti en italie flexibiliser le
marché du travail pour rendre les
entreprises plus compétitives
de l'autre la proche keynésienne ceux à
gauche qui comme françois hollande
préconise la relance par la demande
les libéraux anguel à merkel en tête ne
veulent surtout pas d'ailleurs pour la
chancelière allemande le pacte
budgétaire n'est pas renégociable la
réduction des dépenses doit rester la
priorité et non une relance de la
croissance par les déficits n'est pas
question de remettre en cause la
discipline budgétaire et au contraire
qu'on soit dans affirmé qu'il rétablir l
équilibre des finances publiques en
france d'ici 2017 et que pour ça il y
aurait une loi organique qui
détaillerait année après année les les
efforts qu'il faudra faire pour ça
françois hollande espère convaincre ses
partenaires européens de créer une taxe
sur les transactions financières avec
les états qui le souhaitent d'augmenter
les possibilités de financement de la
banque européenne d'investissement et de
créer des project bones émis par la bce
pour financer des projets industriels
certains redoute un bras de fer mais un
compromis devrait être trouvé
françois hollande est en gala merkel
serait presque condamnés à s'entendre au
fond elle a pas vraiment de choix mais
je pense que l'ensemble des
gouvernements a pas vraiment le choix
aujourd'hui les la récession dans
laquelle on est en train de s'engager en
europe fait peser une menace sur la
sueur sur la d'abord sur l'europe
elle-même
sur la construction européenne parce que
les tensions peuvent pas s'accumuler
comme ça et sans qu'à un moment ou un
autre ça craque pour ça il faut faire
quelque chose et puis à l'intérieur de
chacun des états particulièrement dans
certains états du sud la situation
sociale est pas tenable ne pas prendre
le risque de finir isolé en europe ni
dans son pays
d'autant que la france comme leadership
d'une europe de la croissance et courir
un risque en gueule à merkel elle a
besoin d'un accord avec les
sociaux-démocrates pour gagner les
législatives de 2013 toute concession
faite à françois hollande lui permet
aussi de se rapprocher du spd allemand
alors on va entendre
andrea choix de députés allemands
françois hollande renégocier le traité
budgétaire en y ajoutant un volet
croissance
pas question de renégocier ce traité lui
a répondu un gala merkel est ce que vous
pensez qu'il peut y avoir un bras de fer
franco-allemand sur ce sujet alors je
pense tout d'abord qu'il faut peut-être
protéger un peu françois allant de la
présentation bon les demandes qui leur
ont été présentées d'après ce que j'ai
entendu c'est pas les demandes qui l'a
fait lui-même
bien sûr il a eu et qu'il a exprimé
quelques idées pendant la campagne
électorale et là il a mis le point sur
la croissance
il est clair et c'est 100 questions que
nous tous nous voulons avoir de la
croissance car sans croissance
l'économie en europe ne va pas se
remettre donc ça il n'y a pas de
question mais quand même il faut voir
c'est cette discussion dans un dans une
structure historique
on a eu le problème en grèce on a trouvé
une solution on s'est mis d'accord sur
le pacte fiscal et maintenant on veut
aussi de la croissance mais il est aussi
clair que ce pacte sur lequel on s'est
mis d'accord à vingt-sept ne veut pas
changer du jour au lendemain
et donc il faut trouver maintenant après
les élections en grèce et dans d'autres
pays européens de trouver une solution
pour la croissance en europe
est ce qu'il pourrait pas y avoir quand
même une espèce de compromis à
l'européenne entre angela merkel et
françois hollande c'est à dire bon allez
finalement
mercredi real est d'accord j'accepte la
réouverture des discussions sur sur le
traité et en contrepartie
voilà on se met d'accord aussi sur sur
ce qu'il y aura dans la croissance c'est
à dire pas une croissance par le parent
par les déficits
d'abord il ya des discussions entre là
dessus parce qu'honnêtement moi je
trouve c'est un peu simpliste car en
fait avec les structures que nous avons
en europe que les parlements nationaux
doivent ratifier ce pacte fiscal
on peut pas juste changé quelques mots
ça va pas marcher mais ça veut pas dire
qu'on ne trouvera pas un nouveau
nouvelles et d un nouveau modèle pour
financer la croissance au niveau
européen comment on relance cette
croissance tout le monde prononce on
entend ce mot-là prononcé dans la bouche
de beaucoup de dirigeants européens mais
on nous dit pas comment donc ce n'est
pas par la dépense publique c'est par
des réformes structurelles c'est ça
qu'il faut faire pour ré certainement
différent des différentes pistes qui
sont lancés mais y est d'abord il y à
cette fameuse stratégie 25 que nous
avons élaborée qui était extrêmement
détaillées mais donc pour le moment
la majeure partie avec des priorités
avec des idées phares et ses draps mais
dont la majeure partie devrait en
principe être financée par les états et
évidemment les états ne peuvent pas
financer cette relance tout simplement
parce qu'ils sont acculés par la rigueur
est donc là les moyens les moyens en
tout cas les lignes on les a maintenant
à partir de quelles ressources et qu'est
ce qu'on va faire au niveau européen
comme grands travaux comme possible et
et éventuellement d'emprunts européens
c'est là tout le débat est ce que la bio
y va pouvoir la banque européenne
d'investissement va pouvoir jouer
est-ce qu'on va avoir des euro
obligations est ce que la taxe sur les
transactions financières va servir en
partie au budget européen ou au budget
des états c'est là dessus que porteront
les discussions et les compromis mais je
dirais les solutions la stratégie et
aidera tout est sur la table paul
prescrit à une prise de conscience quand
même que l'europe ne peut pas continuer
fixé sur le cap unique de l'austérité ce
qui est un président en jeu
lance bien mais on ne peut pas dire
qu'il ya une approche keynésienne rien
et proche du béral john maynard keynes
était un libéral c'était un membre de
mon parti ce qu'il a il dit identifée
c'est que parfois surtout qu'on tournait
dans les récessions
il est conseillé à bhl ou gouvernement
de prendre les dépenses pour des années
futures
dans les infrastructures et de les
mettre maintenant tout de suite et c'est
ce qu'essaie de faire l'europe
investir dans les connexions d'énergie
les réseaux de transports les réseaux
d'ordinateurs et et etc sont le bleu
broadband ça c'est important
née en même temps mario monti il il a
raison de 6 il faut aussi certaines
réformes sur le marché de travail
il faut promouvoir le marché intérieur
pour qu'on ait plus de commerce entre
nos pays différents et surtout aussi les
accords de commerce avec des pays tiers
là on parle de la croissance quand on
voit que la grèce par exemple et de
récession art il ya deux années avait
déjà parlé de la croissance parce que la
grèce avait un plan d'austérité en plan
d'austérité sel ça ne va pas on a vu ce
que ça va pas sans croissance
naturellement la croissance doit être
financé je m'appelle qui est le sien
malade avait dit qu'il faut 3 trillions
pour vraiment financer première wii pour
vraiment financer la croissance en
europe
il faut trouver une combinaison entre un
plan d'austérité d'austérité les
réformes structurelles
ils sont nécessaires par exemple à mon
pays ce sont nécessaires des réformes
structurelles et avec les project bonds
ce avec leurs grossistes seront
acceptées est ce que ce débat sur la
croissance honnêtement à athènes et ce
qu'il n'arrive pas trop tard est-ce que
ça fait pas un an et demi on veut dire
des signaux qui arrive de la grèce qui
nous disent mais attendez vous êtes en
train de nous étrangler ça fait
longtemps qu'on les voit cette position
c'était la position d'un autre
parti tout le monde en europe était
férié quand les socialistes
le gouvernement socialiste avait signé
les premiers mémorandum et il disait qui
après des années l'agresseur dans les
marchés ça c'était inimaginable
alors peut-être pas possible justement
je vous propose de nous arrêter sur la
situation en grèce situation grave
puisque les élections qui ont eu lieu
dans votre pays ont profité au parti
extrême qui font une percée inquiétant
je propose tout de suite regardé ce ce
sujet signé n'aura un à dix pendant
qu'on fait la fête place de la bastille
à paris ont fait la débâcle des parties
prospérité dans le centre d'athènes
le pays qui a inventé la démocratie à
laisser parler les urnes et a accouché
d'une crise politique sans précédent
le pasok socialiste et le parti de
droite nouvelle démocratie sorte laminé
de ces législatives et non plus la
majorité au parlement
grand gagnant les partis opposés au plan
d'austérité et au mémorandum imposées
par les bailleurs de fonds la formation
de gauche radicale syriza et le bien
nommé aube dorée un parti néonazi qui
entre pour la première fois au parlement
son charmant dirigeants flanqué d'une
quinzaine de skinheads et d'un emblème
qui rappelle la swastika a affirmé que
son groupe de 21 députés allaient lutter
contre les usuriers mondiaux et
l'esclavagé imposées par l'union
européenne et le fmi
en bien première difficulté former un
gouvernement d'union nationale une tâche
qui s'avère impossible
antonis samaras le leader de nouvelle
démocratie a déclaré forfait et il
semble peu probable qu'une formation
puisse voir le jour
pendant ce temps l'europe et les marchés
s'inquiètent car le temps presse pour la
grèce fin juin
athènes pourrait se retrouver à court de
liquidités et par conséquent en défaut
de paiement
oui font peur à ces images qui nous qui
nous viennent de grèce alors on parlera
peut-être de la montée des populismes de
l'islam droite mais mais un mot
peut-être là immédiatement ce que vous
pensez que ça y est la grèce est au bout
du chemin et qu'avec que ce qui est en
train de se passer dans votre pays la
grèce à sortir de l'euro n'ont d'aucune
façon
et maintenant écouter les grecs dont la
réponse un pourcentage des 77 %
nous voulons être un europe et dans
l'eure et après ils avaient voté parce
qu'il croyait qu'il n'y avait pas un tel
danger par exemple ces partis gauchistes
gauche qui était sorti avec un à peu
près 17 % visés nous sommes en faveur de
l'europe de l'hérault mais on va
renoncer
l'accord qu'on a fait les mémorandums
qu'on a signés avec les européens tout
ça c'est stupide
il y a les populistes comme l'extrême
droite où c'est la première fois que
l'extrême droite prennent place dans le
parlement grec
en grèce on avait il de dictature nous
n'avez jamais deux parties vraiment
fasciste et raciste et c'est la première
fois et c'est peut-être à cause de
l'immigration illégale qui est très
haute en grèce quand on entend les
dirigeants allemands qu'ils vont
maintenant la récréation c'est fini si
la grèce ne tient pas ses engagements
s'est terminée il ya plus un euro pour
la grèce qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que
vous en pensez peut-être aussi en avance
je pense tout les investissements qu'on
a fait en grèce
on veut pas maintenant les voir
disparaître on a le but de garder la
grèce en europe mais c'est aussi
nécessaire que le peuple grec le
confirme franck attend justement où on
en est de l'application de ces réformes
à ce qui a été juste votée est ce que ça
commence à produire ses effets c'est
parti gauche qui a la possibilité de
créer un gouvernement c'est son tour
fait vraiment un campagne électorale
pour les prochaines élections les partis
communistes ne vais pas participer les
autres les populistes ne veulent pas
négocier avec les partis socialistes ego
que nous sommes de force europe 1 alors
quelle issue vous voyez véronique de
keyser à cette situation chaotique
finalement pas le gouvernement je serais
incapable pour le moment de donner une
solution à la grèce sinon que je veux
qu'elle reste en europe parce que pour
moi le départ de la grèce ce serait
vraiment le début de la fin mais vous
avez dit quelque chose à madame jeanne
un coût qui m'interpelle c'est à dire où
il avait dit est ce que ce n'est pas
trop tard à propos de la croissance mais
c'est exactement la question qu'on se
pose aujourd'hui pour l'europe c'est à
dire que si l'europe ne fait pas un
changement de politique je ne dis pas à
180 degrés parce que ça c'est une image
mais s'il ne comprend pas que la
solution dans se trouvait niveaux
d'europe avec une relance de l'emploi
il sera trop tard pas seulement pour la
grèce mais pour les autres pays
regardez les élections françaises bien
sûr je me réjouis de la victoire de
hollande mais marine le pen a fait un
score extraordinaire
disons le tout de même et dans d'autres
pays
regardez les pays bas regardez la
hongrie s'avoue satisfait tout ça quand
vous dites j'ai peur moi j'ai très peur
que dans une crise économique avec des
politiques de rigueur impitoyable qui
semble injuste aux gens parce que c'est
pas eux qui ont provoqué la crise
financière
et qui n'oubliait pas au niveau de
l'europe une réponse nous allons voir se
lever quelque chose enfin ce salut nazi
aujourd'hui dédé parti néo-nazi grain
doit-on voir ça en europe et quel front
démocratique faisons nous est ce que
l'europe admette rossa en sont sales
pour moi ce sont des missions
fondamentales qui vont même au-delà de
l'idée de relance mais c'est le
fondement même de notre idée d'europe
qui est agente sue c'est vrai véronique
l'histoire nous apprend l'histoire des
mines au sol et 930 les années 30 nous
apprendre les dangers
ça c'est clair mais en même temps ce que
les européens est d'attendre des grecs
est ce que nous attendons de tout le
monde sait que ils prennent les mesures
nécessaires pour remettre en ordre leurs
économies
les allemands l'ont fait ce n'est pas
facile les scandinaves l'ont fait très
récement ça a été fait dans les pays
baltes se fait maintenant grand beau
temps en irlande emporté niall on it
mais il faut que ça c'est madame vous
dites la gauche avait signé ce
mémorandum mais la signer avec un
conseil qui était droite c'était pas le
choix de la gauche ce mémorandum il
avait le couteau s'ouvrait la gorge bons
mecs que vous dites ce g watson sur sur
le fait que la grèce à tenir ses
engagements est ce que vous dites
le rni de kaiser sur montée des
populismes en europe
est-ce qu effectivement y'a pas une
réponse européenne qui peut être importé
parce qu'en face il n'y a pas que la
grèce il ya une dizaine en parle de la
france milite dizaine de pays en europe
il est partout alors qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire on est au parlement européen
ici qu'est ce que les démocrates comme
vous qui est autour de cette table
égaler la réponse que vous pouvez
apporter ou prison pouvoir porter moi je
ne parlerai plus j'irai c'est l'idée que
nous sommes nous avons discuté c'est à
dire une solution européenne au niveau
d'une relance économique et les là les
gens en ont marre c'est suffisant ça
sera commençons par ça c'est déjà
immense commençons par ça une fois
arrêté à la koko produit aussi il faut
aller regarder
c'est c'est très important c'est ce qui
s'est passé les dernières années est
horrible chacun dit ce mot et ça apporte
une menace alors il faut changer il faut
changer la façon dont on parle il faut
coopérer et il faut coordonner miers et
il ne faut pas avoir seulement
l'allemagne la france d'apporter les
décisions prête au conseil au conseil à
quelques mots pour répandre la dame
diane à coki ce qu'on arrivait
rapidement je trouve il faut être
honnête aussi les mesures qu'on a pris
c'était des mesures raisonnables mais on
peut toujours faire dans le futur encore
d'autres mais de dire maintenant la
croissance contre l'austérité ça ne fait
pas sérieux
non non je voudrais juste mettre le
point là dessus je trouve au numérique
on a fait c'était sérieux
maintenant on peut trouver d'autres
pistes mais ce qu'on avait c'était pas
tout le sérieux better with mai et que
la croissance ou les as et les décisions
et on soutient les cours deux frères au
niveau européen puisque nous sommes 5
500 millions de da d'habitants dans un
monde où vous avez plus d'un milliard de
d'un bien de deux chinois d'autres donc
si on va nous remettre en ordre sur le
plan économique retrouver la croissance
ce serait au niveau européen est basé
sur les valeurs européen et c'est un
anglais
ce sera le mot de la fin merci à vous
quatre d'avoir été avec nous aucun du
parlement européen pour nous apporter
votre regard sur cette présidentielle
française et sur les événements en grèce
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine même
lieu même heure très bonne ces deux
programmes
à